ce bâtiment c'est l'école primaire b2b
des tourelles à fort de france
en septembre il sera fermé et l'école
primaire mais aussi le déménagement a
commencé en direction de l'école assez
dans la même cour au début des années
2000 ces deux écoles pouvaient
accueillir jusqu'à 400 écoliers
en septembre prochain il n'y en aura que
165 un seul bâtiment suffira donc
largement
autre banlieue de fort de france à
redoute ou deux écoles maternelles sont
voisines
il fut un temps où les habitants du
quartier avaient du mal à inscrire leurs
enfants dans ces établissements
il était très demandé mais en septembre
l'école où elle va fermer
professeurs et élèves ont déménagé 100
mètres plus haut chacune de ces écoles
peut accueillir jusqu'à 150 élèves soit
300 enfants en septembre 2019
ils ne seront au total que 119 comme ab
des tourelles l'une de ces écoles va
fermer faute d'élèves
il faut savoir que lorsque nous avons
une une école avec trois classes nous
sommes obligés de maintenir en état un
bâti qui comporte parfois 15 salles et
donc il convient pour nous de de les
orienter
nous nous font qu'ils sont rares le
monde le sait pour servir la communauté
scolaire et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
de bons moyens qui sont soit mise à
disposition à la fois des enseignants et
des élèves en septembre prochain six
écoles vont fusionner à redoute ab des
tourelles et à gaudissart dans ce
quartier des écoles maternelles se sont
déjà regroupés et en septembre ce seront
les primaires à fort de france chaque
année il ya entre 300 et 400 enfants en
moins dans les écoles maternelles à
cause de la baisse de la natalité
conséquence les écoles ferment mais les
bâtiments seront utilisés à d'autres
fins nous allons peut-être affectée ces
bâtiments à autre chose et
éventuellement nous en débarrasser s'il
est besoin s'en fait sentir
mais il est clair que nous avons quant à
nous une obligation vis-à-vis de la
communauté scolaire donc les enfants les
enseignants et les parents
nous avons une obligation de fournir un
patrimoine
bâti en bonne condition en 2001 il y
avait quinze mille élèves dans les
écoles de fort de france en septembre
prochain
moins de 7000 ceux qui seront en
maternelle et en primaire dans ces
écoles devraient avoir plus de chance
que leurs aînés il ne devrait y avoir en
moyenne que 17 élèves par classe un
déménagement qui a commencé en janvier
dernier avec des consultations avec le
personnel éducatif à la rentrée
prochaine
la ville de fort de france devrait
compter trois écoles de moins